[Music]
an illegitimate son news what does that
mean again like Jon Snow Earth submitted
my lights camera that's Chi fu shut up
Oh Kyle sheriff William chat know
something on Thursday I think William
Shatner wants to stop a man who claims
to be his son from using his last name
whoa who was William Shatner again I'm
so [ __ ] Captain James T [ __ ] Kirk bro
Captain Kirk
William Shatner is Shatner like a name
with a lot of legacy that it's not it's
not a common name he's a legend dude
Shatner it belongs to him it's his name
oh really I don't never met another
gender of you I was a James John Luke
the card Star Trek fan so Shatner was
before my time
so James John Luke James Thomas nurses
jean-luc Picard jean-luc Picard this is
Peter it's Kevin John Luke no Peters
alone you think he John Jacob
Jingleheimer Schmidt from John Jacob
Jingleheimer games John his name is my
name too
every cop yeah so Peters alone he's he's
claiming that William Shatner is
biological father
they just need a 23andme man what the
[ __ ] what is he he won't give him a DNA
test Edna story she won't give who Peter
Sloane wants a DNA test from William
Shatner be there what yeah what the [ __ ]
cuz maybe William Shatner is like I [ __ ]
your buses so many nuts on so many women
I don't even know what the [ __ ] dude he
[ __ ] women from all over the world dude
he was like the most famous man he
probably got like 80 children that he
doesn't use good-looking yeah [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] star trekt at that bus see
he [ __ ] blue aliens green aliens
yellow and I didn't give a [ __ ] oh
that's why he [ __ ] aliens
yeah I do yeah clean our [ __ ] is that
who you know if you trauma
the captain dude yes he's like a parody
of yeah he's a parody of yeah and
Captain Kirk was famous for one of his
one of his quotes is like I like 60
[ __ ] you lost six cities yeah 60
[ __ ] I cannot laugh yeah I like the
[ __ ] with one hi
Peter was adopted and so he went back to
look at to see if you could find his
birth parents and so he found his birth
mother and she was an actress her name
her name was Kate Cathy Bert Cathy Bert
and so she worked with William Shatner
in 1956 and she let him come inside her
as you did in 1956 yes yes so she had a
one-night stand with William Shatner and
so he was told by her that it hurt that
his father is either William Shatner or
this other guy she was a do it ice so
then she should he should get the DNA
from the other guy the other guys AG a
free lucious
he was a cross your fingers let's hope
it's the star so he claims that in 1984
a Hollywood producer named e r-13 who's
a friend of Peters adoptive family that
this producer brokered a one-on-one
meeting between Peter and William
Shatner and that Hollywood producers
ex-wife confirms that that did happen so
we don't know but they're saying that
when they met that William Shatner did
admit to being his father but that he
would never go public with it she's like
I will always deny you it's all fake
that sounds big what does it ever happen
in real life yeah you are my son but if
we go in public I will deny you do you
think I don't need a DNA test the
weirdest thing about this is that this
is sort of the B story to Star Trek to
the Wrath of Khan
starring James Cain James T Kurtz
starring William Shatner I don't even
know slowly in the film he has a son he
finds out that he has a son from a chick
that he had a one-night stand
so you legit watch Star Trek oh [ __ ]
loves I love Star Trek then watch the
the first one I'd like don't watch the
first one to watch the Wrath of Khan the
second movie is that one there
Oh G cast cuz Shatner is legit he gives
the best performance of any Star Trek
captain in any movie in that he's really
brilliant in it so here's that one
Shatner one
and this is Peter okay oh why does he
look older than you and he looks like a
gaffer Hollywood celebrity probably has
plastic surgery like crazy
look at your tummy William Shatner is
Jack Nicholson's dead shadow
he looks older that the world they were
acting together is that some one of his
many episodes of the hour or what's the
[ __ ] is a call not the other limits the
other ones own looks like a Twilight
Zone
well maybe not she looks like she has
great titties probably those classic
titties are all natural titties yeah
those commentators are all triangle
titties they are they're all pointing
very pointy so he did petition to change
his name to legally change his name to
Peter Shatner cuz he says that having
that last name was his birthright but
then William Shatner's people before not
the dad doesn't want you yeah before
anything went through he received a
cease and desist order why is he trying
to be his son so hard I wonder if you'd
want to be his son so hard if William
Shatner was just like a plumber
yeah exactly definitely not because it
sounds like [ __ ] sounds like something
to get me into your life oh okay thanks
Joe
it like linked it yeah so then he's
thinking that Peter is B so Peters
thinking that William Shatner's people
are keeping an eye on him because they
find out they found out about this thing
about him wanting a process his name or
legally changed his name before he even
filed anything and that's when he got
the seasons so he's like you know people
are watching me [ __ ] telling people
at the bar and [ __ ] he's talking about
their own social media great oh my god
yeah they're really watching you Val
like fart I mean it's like two old guys
fighting and I forget that there is
still father and son but it's still like
dude you guys look the same age but back
to the the other guy that could be his
dad so the only thing he knows about him
is that his nickname was chick and that
he was a law student from
so he doesn't really have a lot the mom
really got around huh yeah she led a lot
of guys coming her and [ __ ] did she shot
her sure as [ __ ] got around got her
[ __ ] [ __ ] Hollywood bro she says
she was mending a broken heart
no you were mending that [ __ ] broken
[ __ ] girl that's what that is dude she
was trying to break it all over again
and again that's kind of risky
I wouldn't let guys come inside me if I
was a movie star cuz she was an actress
I want a Joe t-shirt that says that I
want Joe shirt I would like guys I
wouldn't like guys come inside me if I
was a movie star I just think that
that's a nice t-shirt because if she
gets pregnant it's gonna ruin her career
why would she be so risky you speak for
the people my friend responsible you
gotta you gotta use a condom lady kind
of just don't feel that I blame her too
didn't they invent condom Sonny was no
one that's 10 years ago or something I
don't know every other timeline yes um
it was like 10 years ago
or they might not even that hard was
back then the boy had really they had
condoms and said in 1839 oh [ __ ] you use
the works good the manga the modern
latex Connors rubber condom was produced
in 1855 I love how it came before the
light bulb because he's like you over a
hundred where we need first okay we
don't need lights we know that oh ho
thank God invent condoms before the lipo
1189 I also enjoy how a condom was made
in 1855 and people still don't use them
that's the amazing thing but it's made
out of like it's made out of like guts
back then point male lamb guts or some
[ __ ] that's my favorite saying well yeah
that was the first quite crocheted um or
something oh the rubber one is 1850 1855
that was probably like a balloon back
then what about the modern latex one was
it invented by like Malcolm [ __ ]
coño Malcolm cotton you know I mean like
why do they call them condoms yeah
sounds fine he had no like toilet Oh
toilet is the last thing that eliminates
sensation on your penis by 50% I know
why would you create a [ __ ] and then
name it after your family name that's
such a bad idea
they ruined his own family name nobody
wants his last name hey from 10,000 to
13,000 oh sorry you see 10 thousand to a
hundred and what the [ __ ] thirteen
thousand sorry the ten thousand to
thirteen thousand BC that's when they
first had like cave drawings of condoms
and [ __ ] cave drawings of condoms they
didn't have the technology a thousand BC
what was it like a [ __ ] net with a
bunch of like dead men onion article the
Egyptian one no this is from depict
condom use this is the first one where's
the condom oh I want to see this [ __ ]
hieroglyph dude this higher looks gonna
be so [ __ ] fat she looks like a pig
it's gonna be two people [ __ ] and
then the the hieroglyph goes into a guy
just being very disappointed man it's
not that good and then no [ __ ]
without it the next slide I'd like to
think that guys hated Khan for thousands
of years a hundred percent they did oh
yeah oh they would use glans condoms but
Asian upper classes yeah it would just
cover the tip of the penis and then at
1594 they've indeed been in 1594 they
invented glass columns linen condenado
1594 they that's not gonna do [ __ ]
you're gonna bust inside of a casa
stocking records the girl - yeah that
she better be wet is bugged
oh yeah yeah a thousand and one hundred
brave words as if inflamed up to test
out the linen the living that's like a
[ __ ] strainer it doesn't do [ __ ] with
the riveted what the [ __ ] that's what
moats are used that's so stupid that's
like a [ __ ] netted jacket it doesn't
do anything jiggle right that's what I
found out
they're blowing up of condoms in their
titties that kept out she's blowing
condoms they got horny I don't know he's
blowing up the condom to get a morning
that's they used to do that I guess
people did some crazy [ __ ] you know what
Egyptian prostitutes used to do is they
had this mix it was like a anti [ __ ]
spermicide thing but it was made out of
like [ __ ] of an animal yeah and like all
kinds of weird poisons or some [ __ ] yeah
and then they would stick that in their
[ __ ] you look of the puppy that was a
spermicide so glad we're bored of this
area thank you that's what I say people
always look so bad right now I'm like uh
yeah at least we don't have to kill a
snake and then put it on as a condiment
and [ __ ] was the last time you stuck a
dingleberry up your [ __ ] to stop being
[ __ ] right back to your question 1919
is the invention of latex condoms 1919
that's still dirt that's the Great
Depression nurse I have an advance at
all cities what the [ __ ] huh they just
completely stopped advancing since then
cuz they're they're the worst
I hate comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]